تنطلق مساء اليوم الحمله الوطنيه الثالثه
للعمل الخيري خلال شهر رمضان في السعوديه
وذلك بعد موافقه الملك سلمان على اطلاقها
تهدف الحمله الى تمكين وصول الدعم الى
مستحقيه وفق عمليات تبرع امنه وموثوقه عبر
التقنيات الرقميه من خلال منصه احسان كما
ستعمل الحمله على ضمان وصول شريحه كبيره
من المتبرعين الى مجالات خيريه متنوعه
بشكل سريع وسهل وخصصت الحمله مركز خدمه
لتلقي التبرعات
منصه احسان الخيريه اطلقت قبل اكثر من
عامين وتشرف عليها لجنه مكونه من 12 جهه
حكوميه في السعوديه فضلا عن لجنه شرعيه
لضبط عمليات التبرع التي ترد الى المنصه
اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات وثلاثمائه مليون
ريال جمعتها منصه احسان منذ اطلاقها وسط
اقبال من كافه الفئات على التبرع في
قطاعات تنمويه عده استفاد من تلك التبرعات
حتى الان ما يزيد على اربعه ملايين وثمائه
الف مستفيد رقم مرشح للارتفاع بشكل كبير
بعد نهايه الحمله الخيريه الثالثه
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض انضم الينا
الرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه احسان ابراهيم
الحسيني اهلا وسهلا بك خالد اليوم ان شاء
الله حتبدا الحمله باذن الله الحادي عشر
مساء اعطينا يذكر في تفاصيل محيطه بهذه
الحلقه اليوم صدور الموافقه الكريمه من
مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين على اطلاق
الحمل الوطنيه لعمل الخير في نسختها
الثالثه امتداد الدعم الكبير من القياده
الرشيده للعمل الخيري وانطلاق هذه الحمله
يمتد الى نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك وهو
امتداد للدعم ونجاح نسختين الاولى
والثانيه من الحمله الوطنيه للعمل الخيري
في رمضان قبل سنتين حققنا اكثر من 700
مليون ريال في الحمله الاولى وفي الثانيه
800 مليون ريال ونستهدف ان شاء الله في
هذه الحمله تجاوز ارقام استثنائيه حققها
المنصه تبارك كيف اثرها هذه الحمله ومثل
هذه الحملات على العمل الانساني والخير في
السعودي نحن اليوم ونحن نفاخخ بوصول
المنصه الى ارقام استثنائيه مثل وصولها
الى ثلاثه 300 مليون ايضا نفاخر اكثر
بالاثر الذي تحققه المنصه من وصولها الى
المستفيد والاسره الاشد احتياجا وتغطيه
المنصه لعدد من المجالات التعليميه
والصحيه والتنمويه ورعايتها عدد من
المجالات التي تستهدف دخول القطاع غير
الربح في كافه مناطق المملكه اليوم في
منصه احسان مجموعه كبيره من البرامج
والخدمات سواء البرامج مع الجمعيات
الخيريه التي تجاوزت الف جمعيه معتمده وهي
مئه بالمئه وفق معايير الحوكمه للمركز
الوطني تنميه القطاع غير الربحي ووفق
معايير احسان وكذلك الخدمات المربوطه مع
الجهات بحكم ان اليوم منصه احسان تحت
رعايته الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي سدايا فاستفادتها من البيانات
اوجد لها عدد من الخدمات التي ترتبط
بالعدل والسجون مثل فرجت وكذلك خدمه تيسرت
للتنفيذ القضائي وهذه الخدمات اليوم تتاكد
من البيانات وتعرض للمستفيدين او
المتبرعين المستفد المستفيد لاشد استحقاقا
ببيانات يتضح للمتبرع رغبته فيها اليوم
المنصه تسعى ويشاهد المتبرع نوع كبير من
الشفافيه يختار عمر المستفيد منطقته مجال
التبرع كم المتبقي وكم ذهب ويستطيع ايضا
الوصول الى تقارير معلومات مركبه معلومات
منشوره موثقه وهي مربوطه
بالبيانات الرسميه
احسان كيف انت شايفك بال الناس على هذه
المنصه يعني كمنصه للعمل الخيري انت تعرف
كان في جدل كثير حول حول العمل الخيري
بشكل عام والتبرعات التي تقدم يعني وخاصه
التبرعات الخارج او للداخل في اليوم
المنصه الى اي مدى كان هناك قبول تفاعل من
الناس معها يعني اليوم بحمد الله المنصه
تشهد اقبال كبير خصوصا في شهر رمضان من
المتبرعين اكثر من عشره مليون ريال يوميا
من المتبرعين الافراد يوميا من متبرع
بريال وريالين و10 ريالات تكفل يوميا اكثر
من 100 يتيم حالات متعلقه بالسجون وايقاف
الخدمات وغيرها من المشاريع ايضا التنمويه
والجدير بالذكر يعني اقامت منصه احسان قبل
شهر تقريبا حفل تكريم المحسنين وتم عرض
احدى المشاريع وهو مستشفى في المدينه
المنوره بجوار المسجد النبوي بقيمه تجاوز
80 مليون ريال فاقبل المتبرعين بشكل سريع
وخلال نصف ساعه تم تغطيه هذا المشروع فلا
شكله يوم المنصه تشهد اقبال كبير وخاصه في
شهر الخير وفي مواسم التبرعات وباذن الله
خلال العشر الاواخر
سيكون باذن الله للمتبرعين والمنسرين
الدعم الكبير للوصول الى ارقام كبيره في
المنصه
في خطط جديده للمنصه خلال فتره القادمه
خطوط عمل يعني باذن الله طبعا المنصه تسير
وفقه خطه واستراتيجيه معتمده من 12 جهه
حكوميه تشرف على المنصه وهذه الخطط تتمثل
في وجود برامج وخدمات للوصول الى كافه
المجالات واخر الخدمات التي اطلقت يمكن
خدمتين الخدمه الاولى العنايه بالمساجد
تستهدف رعايه المساجد واستقبال التبرعات
لها ومتابعه صيانتها والعنايه فيها بقرب
الشهر الكريم وخدمات ايضا تتعلق
بالعنايه بكبار المحسنين ورفع تقاريرهم
وعكس كذلك اثار هذه التبرعات بشكل
الالكتروني وماتمه اكثر التبرعات اللي
تجيكم في اي برنامج او اي نوع دكتور
بالارقام يعني طبعا اليوم 80% من التبرعات
هي من عشره ريال وعشرين ريال في المبالغ
البسيطه واكثر المجالات التي تستهدف اليوم
مجالات سقي الماء والايتام ورعايته
المحتاجين هذه تستثمر بشكل كبير يليها
تفريج كره بالمساجين ومن كان عليهم حكم
بالسجن مع خدمه
كفاله الايتام وايضا السجون هذه اكبر
خدمتين اليوم عليها اقبال من متبرعين
واهتمام ولذلك خصصت لها خدمات باحسان
للعنايه بهاتين الخدمتين الله يبارك فيكم
ويجزاكم خير شكرا جزيلا
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات